cnn is trying to cover for embattled
anchor quiz cuomo while he and his
creepy governor brother drown in scandal
chris is facing mountain criticism for
refusing to cover the story but he is
getting some support from the liberal
network's so-called
media critic this has been a conundrum
for cnn that has no perfect answer no
perfect solution
some think cnn made it worse by letting
chris interview his brother
when kobe 19 was ravaging new york but
that was an unprecedented time period
and so is this one a famous family in
the news
a governor who soared to the highest
heights last year now falling to the
lowest lows
self-inflicted wounds and a brother who
just wants to do his job just wants to
anchor his show
greg the famous family is having a hard
time
and quote chris cuomo has a lot to say
but he cannot say it
i'm having too much pleasure right now
from that from
everything he just said he is the media
reporter
would he have been would he address the
nuance
of this topic if it had happened at fox
news
or all of these con suddenly he
discovered the complexity
of life and the complexity of reporting
it didn't before it was just
trump supporters racist that was so easy
and fox news should be taken off the air
we didn't need any nuance then but now
i need nuance my favorite part about it
is that so stelter he went to his
sources right
he went to the he went i don't know he
went into the break room and he found
out that chris cuomo just wants to do
his job so i'm being completed i wonder
what his anonymous source
who that was yeah like was that like the
cafeteria lady
or some italian guy whose brother's
governor just say i want to do my job i
i love that he has i just love seeing
the spotlight turned on them and
watching their behavior
change it's it's it's uh it's refreshing
to see them suddenly discover that life
isn't as simple
as they've been playing it they have
they have assigned
so much simplistic blame to law
enforcement for 10 years
right that that was there was no nuance
about cops if there was one cop that did
something bad
it was the entire police report the
police department that was guilty of
systemic racism
right that was there was no nuance there
there was no nuance any time like a
trump supporter posted a meme
clearly that means all trump supporters
are racist there was never any nuance
now they figured it out
good job so will cnn's trying to make
this sound like there's a conflict with
chris cuomo covering his brother andrew
cuomo
that's a very surface level analysis or
defense of the situation this is
actually about chris cuomo
writing statements and emails that then
the governor's office
actually sent out almost verbatim on
behalf of the governor during the
scandal so
there are layers to this that they're
they're not wanting to get into
first even on the journalistic ethical
level that's a convenient position to
take where you were perfectly fine
covering him when he was being lauded
and given
me awards but now that there's criticism
there should be some conflicts of
interest here but you're absolutely
right kitty it doesn't stop there
because chris cuomo is not just covering
the story he is
part of the story helping to craft the
message for governor cuomo
you know i look at this really quickly
and i wonder how does governor cuomo
hold on right now he's lost his
political party
he's lost polling in the state of new
york he's lost every legislator just
about in the state and the only answer
is the same one that keeps chris cuomo
in his job and that is we are watching
privilege
pay play out there's so much talk about
privilege this is fame
a political family these are people born
on third race that think they hit a
triple
and can't imagine now the world is
actually going to hold them accountable
for something this is completely for
both of the brothers a story of
privilege so dana you are very good at
predictions
does the governor stay or does he go but
first of all i want to say that i
actually understood that sports metaphor
and i
was proud of myself it was a very good
one a very good one um
i think a couple things happen that we
have to keep in mind so his chief of
staff resigned
today so not only has he lost all the
people that will just mentioned but when
she
who enabled a lot of this realizes that
she better hop off of this train
and try to save herself if she can
because she's also going to be a witness
in all of this so so
she left the other thing i did not
realize is that
once impeachment starts in the state of
new york he has to step aside as
governor
okay it's not like when we saw the
congress impeach the president twice
where he's like
still at the white house and it's over
because we know it's not even going to
pass it's no big deal
he actually has to leave so i do think
that because you saw his
team float an idea today a deal in which
he
basically would say to the state
legislature i promise
not to run for a fourth term if you
don't try to impeach me
to me that means i think that he knows
one he's not running for
a fourth term anyway and two he knows if
he gets impeached it's all over and he
knows
he's going to get impeached so i think
that i don't know how he leaves
but he leaves so jessica there was
another big resignation
as well today the leader of the time's
up movement
which is supposed to be about defending
women from sexual harassment
and sexual assault at work roberta
kaplan
she actually was helping governor cuomo
go after the women who were
accusing him of doing all these things
and corroborated in this report that we
saw come out so
there's that layer of it too as well as
this time's up hollywood movement that
was
on the left that was supposed to be
standing up for women and the woman who
was running the show
was actually helping to smear the
reputations of the women coming forward
well i think that this is really a
continuation of the story that we've
been seeing
in the aftermath of you know the
beginning of time's up
where people realized actually these
stories are incredibly
textured and they're different in cases
like do you remember at the beginning
that suddenly like harvey weinstein and
al franken are the same
person which is like so unbelievably
ludicrous and i'm sure that al franken
is still
sitting there going like i cannot
believe that i resigned right after what
we have seen happen since there so i
think it was right for her
to resign and and i do as someone well
the only member of the liberal party
at the table i can tell you that people
who
have the same politics of me have really
shifted away from believing in
organizations or supporting
organizations to moving
to case-by-case basis this is what i
think about this
particular instance and greg and i were
talking about this before we came out
here
when the governor cuomo scandals shifted
from the nursing homes to me too
that's when i said this is not going to
end well for him because i think that
people were a lot more comfortable
and felt like there was more fodder to
go after him on this where it seems i
mean these are very real
accusations and tisch james it did not
make her happy i'm sure to have to
release that report they were like
11 plus women so they knew that this was
something that all of society
can get behind right this is something
that we have come up with and you're
going to have president biden who was
forced to
and i'm sure he called cuomo ahead of
time and said i said on stephanopoulos
if the report is bad that you're going
and that was the standard you wanted us
to hold you to
and i've known you for decades and i
loved your dad but
this is the standard that we've set for
the white house has denied that the
president has called andrew cuomo sorry
i do not have no direct questions
he didn't say
may have called but the other thing on
the nursing home issue is it wasn't just
andrew cuomo it was a number of
democratic governors who were also
involved
but once again a nursing home thing so
it's easy to walk away from we now have
nuances complex there was a
complexity i love nuance though i know
but before
we didn't have any nuance now we have
nuance lots of nuance
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else